mit den drohen Attacken auf Moskau habe
die Ukraine nicht direkt zu tun so sagt
es der Berater des ukrainischen
Präsidenten im Fernsehen
wir müssen das nicht machen denn wir
haben genug damit zu tun Angriffe in den
besetzten Gebieten auszuführen mit
knappen Waffen darunter Drohnen und
Raketen außerdem machen wir uns mehr
Sorgen über die russischen Angriffe auf
unsere Hauptstadt jede Nacht
drohnenattacken Dienstag am frühen
Morgen wurde Moskau laut russisch im
Verteidigungsministerium mit acht
unbemannten Flugobjekten attackiert die
alle zerstört worden sein
die Leute haben geschlafen da war so ein
Summen und dann hat es laut gekracht als
wäre etwas eingeschlagen
verantwortlich sei die Ukraine sagt der
russische Verteidigungsminister joygu er
spricht von terroristischen Attacken
gegen russische Zivilisten mit
naturwaffen die Regierung in Kiew
dementiert zumindest eine direkte
Beteiligung
im Gegensatz zu diesen Angriffen vor dem
neunten mai handelt es sich jetzt ja um
größere Drohnen die die Reichweite haben
aus der Ukraine auch nach Moskau zu
fliegen das war nichts relativ eindeutig
Ukraine
Kriegslärm und schlaflose Nächte wovon
die Menschen in Moskau nur eine Ahnung
bekamen ist in der Ukraine zermürbender
Alltag geworden
Dienstag am frühen Morgen stürzten in
Kiew Trümmerteile in ein Wohnhaus
verwüsteten zweistockwerke eine Frau
stirbt mehr als ein Dutzend verletzte
verstanden wir das unser Haus getroffen
wurde wir streifen uns etwas über und
rannten die Treppe hinunter
Kampf am Himmel gegen russische Drohnen
sogar tagsüber
der ukrainische Präsident dankte
Deutschland in einem Telefonat für die
bisherige militärische Unterstützung
heute habe ich mit Kanzler Scholz
gesprochen vor allem über die
Luftverteidigung ich habe ihm für die
bereits erhaltenen Systeme gedankt die
geretteten Leben
der Kanzler wiederum hat laut seinem
Regierungssprecher im Telefonat die
unverbrechliche Solidarität mit der
Ukraine bekräftigt
da bleiben wir noch einen Moment bei den
Drohnenangriffen auf Moskau gestern und
schalten zu unserer zdf-korrespondentin
guten Morgen nach Moskau für über der
Kreml wirft der Ukraine ja vor hinter
den Drohnen Angriffen zu stehen was sind
die weiteren Reaktionen in Moskau auf
die Angriffe von Präsident Putin und in
der Bevölkerung
also Präsident Putin hat gestern für
meine Begriffe auffällig zurückhaltend
reagiert er hat die Vorfälle zwar
kommentiert aber am Rande quasi
beiläufig neben einer Veranstaltung zu
einem ganz anderen Thema und er hat
diese drohnenattacken zwar als Terrorakt
der Ukraine gewertet aber er hat sie
eben nicht genutzt um die
Eskalationsspirale weiter zu drehen
womöglich sucht man im Kreml noch nach
der passenden Antwort auf diese Vorfälle
und ganz sicher ist man bemüht den
Eindruck zu erwecken diese Lage hier im
Griff zu haben die Frage ist allerdings
ob und wie lange die russische
Bevölkerung den Kreml das noch abkauft
denn eines ist ganz klar zum Beispiel
war es gestern nach diesen Attacken so
dass sich in einigen telegram-kanälen
hier die Moskauer und mosklerinnen
darüber ausgetauscht haben wo sie im
Zweifel falls es zu neuen Luftangriffen
kommen sollte unterschlug finden können
wo es also Bunker gibt oder andere
Möglichkeiten sich in Sicherheit zu
bringen und immer öfter sind besorgte
Stimmen zu hören das haben wir schon in
den letzten Tagen und Wochen bemerkt das
spielen natürlich die inzwischenfälle
entlang der ukrainische russischen
Grenze eine Rolle erst heute Nacht gab
es wieder einen Angriff auf eine
öl-raffinerie im Süden Russlands und
diese Drohnenangriffe die haben eben
neben den faktischen Auswirkungen auf
eine psychologische Komponente und die
entfaltet ihre Wirkung mehr und mehr
vielen Dank für diese Informationen für
Bewerber das Live in Moskau und bei mir
im Studio ist jetzt der ukrainische
Botschaft in Deutschland olexes schönen
guten Morgen Herr Botschafter guten
Morgen
Berater von ein Berater von Präsident
selenski hat gesagt die Ukraine habe
nicht direkt etwas mit dem
Drohnenangriffen auf Moskau zu tun was
bedeutet das
dazu kann ich leider nicht mehr sagen
das vombereitetes Präsidenten sie
gestern gehört haben etwas bestätigen
oder revidieren kann ich heute nicht was
aber wichtig ist dass Russland nach
Erklärung und sucht und wie wir von von
ihrer Kollegen gehört habe gibt es keine
Erklärungen wieso jetzt die
drohnen-attacke auf Moskau ein Akt ist
aber ein einjähriges Krieg mit täglichen
beschissen von Kiew kein Akt des Terrors
nicht nur Moskau sucht nach Erklärung
auch der Westen sucht nach Erklärung
vielleicht dieses könnt ihr ein Akt des
Krieges sein das heißt noch mal die
frage ich muss noch mal nachhaken wenn
die Ukraine nicht direkt etwas damit zu
tun hat heißt es doch sie könnte ihn
direkt etwas damit zu tun haben
äh es könnten auch die russischen drohen
sein aber hier spekulieren kann ich
leider nicht ich bin Botschafter und ich
muss klar in meinen Ansagen und
Erklärungen sein leider dazu kann ich
heute nicht äußern Präsident selenski
hat ja immer versichert dass die Ukraine
Russland nicht auf dem Territorium
Russlands angreifen wird trotzdem macht
sich der Westen jetzt Sorgen die USA
haben gestern gesagt sie unterstützen
keine Angriffe der Ukraine auf
russisches Territorium bekommen Sie da
wenn das jetzt so weitergeht und das war
jetzt auch nicht der erste Angriff von
Drohnen in Russland Probleme mit den
westlichen Partnern wir müssen verstehen
wir sind seit 9 Jahren im Krieg und seit
einem Jahr
beschützt Russland uns aus eigenem
Luftraum und auch aus dem Gebiet von
Bella aus fast jeden Tag nur im Mai
hatten wir mehr als 170 Drohnen
abgefangen und mehr 370 Drohnen und mehr
als 100
64 Marschflugkörper aus Russland können
Sie sich vorstellen was wäre gewesen
wenn wenn die alle getroffen werden und
nicht von
ukrainischen ukrainischer Flugabwehr und
von deutschen
flughafen-systemen wie Geparden wie
irishi und Patrioten was wäre gewesen
und mein ganzes Land schläft seit drei
Wochen überhaupt nicht wegen dieser
täglichen nächtlichen
ein Angriffen deswegen wir müssen uns
verteidigen und wenn ein Flugzeug
anfliegt oder wenn wenn aus der Nähe von
der Grenze unsere Position beschossen
werden wir haben dieses
verteidigungsrecht heute beginnt in Oslo
das Treffen der NATO Außenminister immer
mehr NATO Mitglieder können sich eine
Mitgliedschaft der Ukraine in der NATO
vorstellen welchen Zeitpunkt halten sie
da selbst für realistisch
wissen Sie wir müssen endlich mal von
dieser
Geiselhaft von von Bukarest loswerden
was meinen Sie im 2008 wurde in Bukarest
entschieden das Ukraine
NATO-Mitglied sein wird und seit 2008
hören wir immer wieder Ausreden warum es
zu dieser NATO Mitgliedschaft noch nicht
gekommen ist ich glaube Ukraine hat
bewiesen wir sind ein stolzes
kämpferisches Land und wir sind heute
alleine dafür verantwortlich dass
russische Aggression nicht weiter nach
nach Europa kommt sondern wir kämpfen
auch mit
ausländischen Waffen deswegen
Ukraine wird dazu beitragen dass jeder
im Euro atlantischen Raum sich sicherer
fühlt wenn wir NATO Mitglied werden aber
klar ist für viele NATO Mitglieder auch
so lange sich Ukraine in einem
Krieg mit Russland befindet ist die
Mitgliedschaft nicht denkbar das können
wir auch bestätigen und das Bestreben
wir wir nicht wir müssen diesen Krieg so
schnell wie möglich gewinnen aber was
wir von NATO erwarten und auch was wir
von Wellness damit erwarten dass uns ein
klarer Weg zur NATO Mitgliedschaft
gezeigt wird und auch dafür gesorgt dass
Ukraine die notwendigen
Sicherheitsgarantien bekommt bis wir
NATO-Mitglied werden so wie es zum
Beispiel im Falle von Finnland und
Schweden passiert ist vielleicht noch
eine kurze Frage zur groß angekündigten
Frühjahrsoffensive über die wir jetzt
fast schon seit nicht nur Wochen sondern
Monaten berichtet man hat das Gefühl die
kommt nicht
ich weiß nicht wieso haben sie dieses
Gefühl sie kommt bestimmt das hat unser
Präsident auch vor kurzem gesagt vor ein
paar Tagen dass alle Vorkehrungen schon
getroffen
sind wir sind dazu bereit wann es
passiert wird natürlich nicht
vorangekündigt aber wir müssen unsere
Gebiete und unsere Menschen befreien und
diesen Krieg gewinnen Hilfe Deutschlands
in diesem Zusammenhang ist
außerordentlich wichtig und unser
Präsident hat in den letzten zwei Wochen
Bundeskanzler Scholz schon zweimal
persönlich getroffen gestern haben sie
telefoniert weitere Treffen sind auch
geplant und wir sind in einem sehr
intensiven und pragmatischen Dialog zu
Gast war bei uns der ukrainische
Botschafter Alex vielen Dank dass Sie da
danke schön